well against another top player team  rajabov winning two in a row the  youngest player in the tournament at  only 18.  wow the youngsters they are here to  fight for uh the knockouts that's true  and also  jew engine has lost against levon  aronian so this is uh great news for  levon ironian because his loss in the  second round against uh argent aragasi  was horrible yeah i mean it's the type  to actually ruin your tournament that  kind of loss and okay  well he is following the real book  jeffrey he's just protected his king and  now he's just gonna escort his pawn  towards his well  to where it wants to go the b8 square  first he has to take care of the f2 pawn  done that  and now  that's it  yeah aaron tarry has resigned two pawns  down in a hopeless position but hats off  to jeffrey shaw he's on fire yeah it's  over another win for the young america